this is based on a joint work with two
you vowels
you've out the gun and his advisory Val
Kilmer's and yet Yoli who is my current
PhD student all right so I'm going to
talk about some problems in complexity
theory in particular communication
complexity and they say that the first
slide of a good math text should be
accessible to general public but I'm
going to put some technical things here
on this first slide but I'm gonna break
this rule I promise the next slide will
be easy sir this is mainly I'm gonna say
what kind of problems we are I'm going
to talk about in this talk for people
who know the notation but I'm then I'm
going to step back and define those
notations so it will be something in the
communication to party communication
model for those who are familiar with
this and the main question is that when
you allow an error of Epsilon how much
you can save in communication complexity
compared to the case where you're not
allowing any error and in particular if
you're familiar with this notation I'm
interested in there some tallix of this
difference the zero error versus the
epsilon error and there's an underlying
distribution mu and a more concrete
example would be for example for the and
function just a two-bit and function so
you have two players one has one bit the
other one has another bit that they want
to see what is the end of those in one
case they don't want to make any
mistakes the other case with probability
epsilon they're allowed to make a
mistake and we're interested in this the
behavior of this thing with respect to
epsilon and if you've worked in
communication complexity probably
similar to me you've developed this bad
habit that you don't care about
constants but once you move to
information complexity constants become
important and particular like for
something like an function it makes
sense to actually study what is this
information complexity and this is a
constant and it's calculated computed
very recently with this really nice work
by Braverman and on Kate Denis Denis and
hombre and it has really interesting
applications which I'm gonna get to
so yeah for example what is this
asymptotics now if you are a flyer so
now the much-anticipated second slide is
that all right so what is information
complex see it's just the continuation
of Shannon's information theory and its
really a recent area and I find it
really beautiful many of these results
in this area so what is Shannon setting
we have two players Alice and Bob so
let's say this bald one is Bob and
there's one-way channel and what they
want to do is so Alice is receiving many
samples from a single random variable X
so these are just getting samples and
these are independent samples so they
have the same distribution but they are
independent now she wants to transmit
this to Bob so she wants to send one
message from which Bob is supposed to
recover this X 1 to X n and with some
small probability let's say he might say
I can recover or he might recover
something wrong and the question is how
much how many bits does she need to send
an average as n grows asymptotics with
respect to n and this important theorem
of Shannon she's known as Shannon's
source coding theorem says that if you
take this number of bits divided by n as
n grows this converges to the so called
entropy of the random variable X which
has a nice formula and from this you can
say in a sense that this entropy really
captures the essence of this random
variable how many bits of information is
in is inherently there in this random
variable X and you really see this when
you go to this kind of amortized way
that you have many copies if you just
have say one bit it's hard to really
have a me get this kind of algorithmic
meaning for it's like two you just get a
formula but doesn't really mean much but
once you have this amortized way of
looking at it the entropy really comes
up comes out of it naturally all right
so that's Shannon setting now in Shannon
setting Bob is quite passive right it's
just sitting there waiting to get this
message and decode it
now in communication complexity they're
allowed to interact so Alice sends a
message Bob send something back and
let's say we have a distribution
and these input so let me say what is
this communication complexity model the
standard one so let's say Alice receives
a random variable X input X Bob receives
our random variable Y and they're
sampled from some joint distribution of
Y so they are not necessarily
independent they can be always the same
or with some probability the same and so
on there can be some correlations there
and now what they want to do is they
want to compute some function and they
want to collaborate to do that for
example they want to see whether these
two inputs are the same or not the
Equality function one of the important
functions in communication complexity
and now how many bits do they need to
really communicate to do this test to
compute this value of the function f to
see whether their inputs are the same or
not for example that's the setting of
communication complexity so there are
two main tasks communication tasks that
are often studied so let me define these
and we'll work with these in this talk
so you have a communication protocol
which says how they gonna interact and
what they're going to output so let's
denote that by PI and this pi has access
to randomness so these Alison Bob they
can flip coins and according to which
decide what to do which message to send
and so on and in the first task that I'm
interested in which I'll denoted by F
and epsilon what they want to achieve is
that for every x and y every single
possibility of x and y the probability
that something goes wrong is at most
Epsilon
so this is independent of the
distribution of x and y every single x
and y that we pick you want to achieve
this so this probability the randomness
in this probability is really coming
from this randomness in the protocol the
coins that Alice and Bob are tossing not
from the input to input is for every X
on one the second one task is the
distribution of tasks which I'll put
this mu here to say that in addition to
the randomness in PI now we also sample
the inputs randomly so x and y are also
sampled according to some distribution
mu and now what I care is that okay so
if you sample this input randomly and
you run your random protocol what is the
probability that an error happens so in
the second task this is what I'm
interested and of course this is an
easier task compared to this one right
for every Mew
if you can do this of course you can do
this for every meal now the common
notations in communication complex is
that the communication complexity of the
first task is often denoted by this are
epsilon of f2 randomized communication
of F the second one is this distribution
all its D mu epsilon of F but I'm going
to stick to this notation see see didn't
standing for communication complexity of
this two tasks all right so that's these
two tasks and simple minimax theorem
which appears in yahoo's important paper
which kind of initiated this area says
that this one is it's of course an upper
bound for every single one of these
things but there exists the Mew which
actually gives you exactly this the
communication complexity of this first
task so this there is a there is a
difficult Mew the most difficult mu
which actually is as hard as doing it
for every single input all right so
that's the main maxim now something more
recent information complexity so here
this is an extension of Shannon's
information theory and it's in the
setting of communication hypothesis so
the setting is exactly the same they
want to call collaboratively compute
this f of X Y but now they don't care
about the amount of information so they
can talk as much as they want exchange
as many bits as they want but what you
are interested is how much information
they are revealing but by communicating
so it's this thing that is called
information cost so as they communicate
they learn more about each other's input
right initially Alice's X pop has why
they might be independent so in that
case they don't know anything about each
other's input but as they communicate
slowly they start learning things from
each other's input and we want to
minimize that and we can measure that
using entropy right it's how we measure
information so the exact definition is
here but it really doesn't matter for
this talk you can completely ignore it
if you're familiar with this
things yet so that's the definition but
you might as well ignore it for this
talk so information cost so a protocol
is really how much Alice learns about
Bob's input plus how much Bob learns
about Alice it's an input from the
communications and measured by this
mutual information for me like this
addition and to be able to talk about
information you need to have a
distribution move this distribution Mew
is what gives you some information
content content to these random
variables right right so it's obviously
upper bounded by the sum of the
entropies of x and y but can be much
smaller or close to that all right so
I'm I'm ready to denote that with this
thing information cost of Pi with
respect to measure Mew all right so now
if you have a communication task of
course you can say how well how much do
you need to pay in terms of
communication costs to be able to
perform this task so that would be the
infimum over all protocols that perform
this task so you look at their
information costs of all of them and you
take the infimum and here you can't take
the minimum infimum is necessary even
for something simple as the end function
you can have you really don't have a
single protocol which achieves that you
you can construct the sequence of those
duties all right so that's the
information cost of a a task and of
course the two tasks that I said we
mostly interested are this one F epsilon
and F mu epsilon where now I'm measuring
information error with respect to Nu and
measuring information with respect to MU
so these two don't necessarily have to
be the same thing so here I'm interested
in computing F where if I sample inputs
according to this distribution you have
a epsilon chance of making an error but
I'm measuring information with respect
to MU so that's a different thing that's
how I measure the information all right
so we have these two things now
so remember Shannon's theorem that when
you look at amortized cost of this
transmission it corresponds to entropy
and there's this beautiful theorem by
Braverman a row from 2010 which says
something very similar is happening here
now let's look at this task of computing
F distribute with distributional error
Epsilon
now suppose you want to do that n copies
of the same task so Alice gets n inputs
x1 to xn Bob gets n inputs y 1 to y and
where every pair is drawn from the same
distribution mu independently and now
they want to communicate and solve all
these problems at the same time so that
for each single one of them the
probability that they're making an error
is at most Epsilon and if you look at
the communication cost of this this is
not the information it's just
communication in the amortized sense
when divided by n it converges to the
information cost so it's a really
beautiful theorem says ok again the same
thing this essence of this communication
is captured by this information and you
see it when you look at it in an
amortized way how you do it in sine of
time simultaneous way solving all of
them and this is for epsilon larger than
0 for 0 it's so a mystery you don't know
exactly and there is another one which
now let's look at this task so this is a
paper later by braverman it showed that
for this one you converge to the
following thing now now what I'll get is
that I pick the hardest distribution mu
and look at the information costs of
computing this task so computing F
correctly on all the inputs with error
at most epsilon and a simple min/max
argument shows that I can write it in
this form that now I look at the hardest
distribution mu in terms of information
and hardest distribution new for the
error and look at computing this
performing this task of computing F with
distributional error new at most Epson I
haven't seen really this written
anywhere but I'm pretty sure it's known
to people so it's a simple observation
basically it's kind of from this it's
easy to see how these two things relate
really ok so we have these two
observations they wrote or theorems not
really observations they really both
great theorems it's written up there now
from those kind of Braverman
define the following so if you look at
those you would want to define the
following thing which is prior free
information complexity which is let's
look at the hardest distributions and
see how what is lower bound we can get
for the information and these are good
for obtaining lower bounds for
communication complexity so one is just
looking at this one the second one let's
call that prior free information
complexity of F there is no distribution
here it's really for F and epsilon right
because both distributions are maximized
here and now also you can look at the
second the first one here and look at
the hardest mu so you can maximize that
and Braverman called that distribution
all prior free information cost of F and
that's nice yes the new is the error so
you sample the inputs from new and you
want the property that you're making an
error is at most epsilon when you do
that now mu is something that comes when
you're measuring the information costs
right all right so from this so here we
have the same thing now obviously from
by looking at this you see that this is
a lower bound for the this one right
because here these two have to be the
same here they're free to be anything
but what Ramon observed is that proved
so this first one is not that difficult
but if you if you don't allow any error
so when your epsilon is 0 these two
things are the same but when you allow
error so when you have epsilon larger
than zero they are roughly equivalent
what you get is that as I said this one
is obvious but what we showed is that
you can upper bound this one if you're
willing to decrease your epsilon by a
little bit so you're multiplying it but
some alpha which is less than one also
you're multiplying this whole thing by
constant is slightly larger than one so
you're paying in both ways so a larger
than one constant here and you're
decreasing there but it's not that bad
say if you take alpha to be 1/2 you get
2 here and you get Upsilon over 2 here
so that's what he proved this early
interesting proof and what she asks
after that is an open problem is that
are they actually equal so it might as
well be the case that for every epsilon
these two things are equal it's not just
a zero so that was one of the questions
in that paper and as as well as I'll
mention later in this talk we should
know they are not the same and right
information yeah just back to the same
yeah exactly right so the counter
example will be set disjointness which
is really the probably most important
function in communication complexity so
this in this problem Alice and Bob
received two sets they want to know
whether they intersect or not right so
if there is no intersection let's say
the valued output is one if there's some
intersection deputies view and this is
it was so people start worked on trying
to prove lower bounds for this and it
was really in early 90s that finally it
was shown that you really need linear
number of bits to communicate and it was
a short profile which is short but not
very easy which shows exactly so you get
a lower bound but in this sense which is
usually but people are happy to have in
communication complexity don't care much
about the constants right so we have
this theorem from nineties and one thing
about this function disjointness is that
it's really nothing but all of ends
right if you if you encode these two
sets is just vector zero one valued
vectors what you want to compute is you
look at all these ends these ants
correspond to intersection right if
they're one if an element I in is in
both x and y so if if something is like
that you get a 1 here and then you're
taking the order of those so that's
really the intersection I have to negate
it to get this joint right so you have
this nice structure but that's kind of
ringing the bell that this really looks
like an amortized and right so you're
you want to really compute a lot
the man's at the same time so maybe
something related to those amortized
results in fact yeah in this paper of
Braverman and squatters they use these
ideas with together with some previous
things that come from previous sources a
really long paper a lot of ideas and
theorems they managed to prove the
following that they managed to nail down
the exact constant as epsilon goes to 0
so let's look at the communication
complexity of computing disjointness as
I said it's already pretty hard to show
that this is linear but they made sure
that as epsilon goes to 0 they you get
this constant so you're converging to
this zero point for a to seven n plus
this little of n and this constant is
really coming from the and function what
is this constant it's the communication
information cost of computing the
two-bit and function with no error zero
error but also you're only interested in
measures were supported on everything
but this point one one Sowmya one one
has to be zero so you're out of the four
points your measure is supported and at
most the other three ones 0 0 1 and 0 0
so you kind of cross off this from your
measure and you look at those
distributions you can find out which one
is the hardest and compute this thing so
this is really the heart of this paper
it's really not easy to compute even for
this two-bit Punk
function what is the exact information
cut because so you get this cousin and
that's really what's happening there
right and then they ask the following
two questions in the paper that's right
so this is true and epsilon goes to 0
what if we care about the rate of
convergence so what if epsilon some
other small constant how big this thing
is or how big this one is for this
chiness and the same question for
communication complexity how does it
behave if you actually want to have an
epsilon here which and not just a limit
and yeah so we looked at these questions
and they're kind of all related to each
other so our so one of our main theorems
is that yeah this is really of the order
of entropy of epsilon which is epsilon
log X 1 right so if you look at the and
function the information complexity of
an function 0 versus epsilon error
asymptotically this is a qualen 2h
epsilon so the amount to gain is the
entropy of epsilon and the same thing
for disjointness and communication
complexity of disjointness so this
constant that we had previously there
you can decrease it by something which
is asymptotically of the order H Epsilon
if you're allowing this error epsilon
and this these are not easy theorem so
the upper bound is fun and easy so you
kind of play with and you come up with a
nice protocol and stick gains H Epsilon
but proving lower ban was quite hard for
this one so we try to generalize the
methods that they had and in theory you
can generalize the framework but then
you can really apply it and one thing is
that for zero error there is this buzzer
protocol which we know it's optimal but
for epsilon error there isn't we don't
have any conjecture what is the optimal
protocol and if you don't know what is
the optimal protocol you can really work
with their framework which is checking
these like local convexity condition and
I think in this case even if you know
what is the protocol it wouldn't be easy
to check that because you'll have so
many other variables right so for a
while we were working with this but in
the end we took a completely different
approach we proved some stability
results and from that we managed to get
this result it's really it's like that
these ten pages prove to just get this
simple like foot and functionary all
right and the other thing we did was we
looked at destroy dysfunction and now in
this other prior free thing so
distribution all prior free so now I
give you a distribution mu and you want
to upper bound this one and
interestingly here you can save more you
can save instead of H epsilon square
root of H epsilon but you're paying this
log in here which doesn't matter much if
n is big compared to epsilon so you gain
more here and this is the same constant
as before right so this is how we
separated those prior free and
distribution or prior free quantities
questions of Braverman so from this
right so it shows that for disjointness
these two things are not the same and in
fact we get more that actually
the Bravermans inequalities sharp not
only these these two things are not
equal also in addition to that is that
just the analysis that yet that
inequality with alpha is sharp with the
right value of alpha you cannot even
improve that inequality it was quite
interesting because I mean that
inequality didn't seem to the beginning
which would be something that sharp is
just something that came out of the
proof all right okay so for this one
right so this is an upper bound and it's
fun again because you need to come up
with the protocol which does that and
the way you we solve we get this upper
bound is the following so you take a
random order of the bits so from like
take a permutation of 1 to n and you do
the following so you try to compute
these and functions one by one starting
from the beginning and if you find an
intersection you're done right if you
find an element which both of you have
that habit you're done so that's your
goal you'll stop at that moment so what
you do is to compute the N function of
this you you you run a protocol which
comes from this analysis of the end
function that has this much error where
P is this quantity but also you only
allow one sided error this one arrow to
zero means that if it's if if the end is
zero you don't want to make a mistake
you don't want to miss that so your
protocol is that allowed to make an
error there but if the end is one if
both your bit and Alice and Bob's bit
are one they might make him mistake with
this probability so it's really
important that it's one-sided otherwise
you wouldn't get a protocol so you get
something like this and then you care
about also how you're measuring this
information cost so these are the
marginals conditions some events so then
I think this is the protocol then you
have to analyze it and analysis is a
2-page it's not that bad and out of that
you get this kind of nice upper bound
right so it's coming from that all right
ok so let me jump to open problems
I think this is a really nice open
problem it's really about again nailing
down the exact constant so our proofs
show the following thing shows that so
let's look at the computing disjointness
function with epsilon error look at
information cost or if you want you can
look at the communication cost so our
epsilon doesn't matter if you divide
that by n it's not that hard to show
that that's lower bounded by this thing
computing the ant function with epsilon
error the information cost with those
particular distributions that don't put
any mass on one one right so you get
this lower bound here but now let's move
to one side a terror so now I'm
interested in the same thing but more
restrictively so now I don't want you to
make an error if there is no
intersection so this again means that if
the output is zero you're not making an
error the only error that you're allowed
is that changing the output one to zero
so that's one side of there of course if
you add this restriction you're
increasing the information costs right
so you get this and now you can upper
bound this by the previous kind of
protocol similar to what I had in the
previous slide by computing the ant
function one side of there right so you
have this kind of these two things are
sandwiched between these two things and
the good thing is that whether you'd
want to do with one-sided or two-sided
you still have the edge epsilon error so
that's how we get this edge epsilon game
and solving there conjecture what what
it seems to be true which right there's
a cut conjecture is that this thing is
really this seems to be the right
constant for both of them so maybe we
can put this even in the lower bound
here so that would be really interesting
right so that will tell us that the
information cost of this destroy nests
with epsilon error again as I said you
might as well write here R epsilon of
this trainers so it's really if you're
just interested in communication
complexity asymptotically converges to
this constant so this constant times n
that's the right asymptotic now what
discuss
there's probably hard to compute we
might not be able to compute it easily
but it is a nice meaning right you're
just computing the ant function with
one-sided error epsilon error so this
would be nailing down the exact constant
for the communication costs of
disjointness when you have epsilon error
alright so yeah yeah one other open
problem say that I would run out of time
but I put it as a back-up plan is that
so what we proved is more general it's
really not about ant function is that
indeed for every function f you gain
each epsilon so the upper bound is true
for every function f so when you're
allowing epsilon error you gain each
epsilon but for the lower bound what we
managed to prove in the general case is
only square root H epsilon and this is
as epsilon goes to 0 and it seems that
maybe the upper bound is always true
maybe what we saw for the ant function
is in general true so definitely we can
prove equality here if if mu is a full
support so the trouble here are weird
measures which are not a full support
and their support is very like a very
restricted so they're kind of abnormal
canned measures but they might be a
counter example there so we can't really
prove a lower bound of a chips on there
all right so that's another open problem
I think I'll stop here
[Applause]
have a question so units example for the
endfunction whistle what let me get it
right for disjointness the end function
right for these wishes it was the L
function now the quadratic gap was
destroying this all right this H Epsilon
this one this is the strand and this is
a bit different because this is not
really about epsilon goes to 0 compared
to n because I have this additive error
here so the other things are really like
you fixed N and then you let your
epsilon goes to 0 like your interest in
that so it's this is really not a
counter example to the last open problem
[Applause]